[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant de retrouver la ligue 1 on est
toujours quasi challenge passe de nani
on est où là qu'est ce qu'il a c'est à
dire tout le monde trouve ça tout le
monde est à poil et sachant que
c'est normal ce n'est pas leur tellement
vous l'aviez déjà vu tout nu non mais
bcbg a besoin d'être le seul est gêné
non du tout une époque famine c'est ça
la téloche maintenant même dans motus
tout montre à tous les bas alors
attention ça le fait bertand rien allez
la toile sordo vous connaissez car à
bien des fagnes c'est aussi et cyril
aussi à vous étiez là vous l'aviez vous
avez un petit truc à dire que cette
année il a déjà assez de problèmes avec
les cheveux on va pas en rajouter non
plus oui ça marche pas mal sûr il faut
un peu de temps avant on fait là on a on
sait pas croiser avant parce que sinon
ça marche bien tu des ricains ce soir au
bar où il ya du derrick may et enfin que
sa salle a battu e est-ce qu'il faut
retrouver lui là il est beau mais vous
vous êtes plus beau oui vous êtes le
plus beau des animateurs merci mon chéri
marie à la perfection
oui vraiment pardon au temps pour moi
je vous rappelle bertrand vous voit nue
ans
chami
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est parfait c'est parfait merci
c'est parfait merci bertrand casilla
mais ça me gêne puis je vois les
épilations que tout le monde sait
quelque chose
le lac est très poilu mais les gens
n'ont pu piquer
il ya tous les styles quoi voilà et il
est chroniqueur mes chroniqueurs j'ai la
chance qu'ils aient le pupitre devant
vous remettez vous d'avoir un messie dit
des trucs mais non mettez vous demain
mais j'ai pas commenté les invités
peuvent rester derrière la belle à la
frêle crois vraiment qu'ils ont d'avoir
des mois que s'arrachent unique elle
alors sont pas bons comme ça il y avait
à boire et à manger quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stéphane c'est parce que rien des trucs
et programmant le rap et guillaume
guillaume et frédéric vous êtes avec nos
francs chevaux vous remarquez voilà on
peut le dire aux télés spécialisées
n'ont réussi russie n'ont dans leur sang
ne pas les contredire pour dire s'il se
poser la question si tu va dans leur
sens ah bien sûr gagner 38 points allez
on va faire la chronique de camille
comme ça vous fait léger recul mais on
dirait qu'on est on est on dirait qu'on
est dans belle toute nue ça rigolait
comment il ya mathieu mais il est il y
fit pas une fixe l'alleud
mathieu ça va vous suivez oui vous êtes
fixés bertrand vous le trouvez beau oui
les bobos bertrand niveau afin qu'une
petite danse à bertrand est nommé
ils pédalent de musique à l'époque le
monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à vos places les chéris bercy travaille
bertrand ça vous appelez la drogue est
dense ces particules camille combal et
là c'est pas des mots qui habille ses
partir ce soir afin de prôner qu'il y
aura bien sûr un nouveau d'erich croisé
rihanna horloge m a dit qu elle adorait
nord guillaume et frédéric vous êtes
déjà fait une bêtise et puis j'avais ou
alors si vous avez vous souvenez de
quelque chose nous c'était pour me
souvenir d'un chagrin d'amour
oui et on a associé une mauvaise odeur à
la personne oui et cette fois qu'on me
prononcer son nom que je pensais à lui
j'avais envie de vomir ces forçats
atroce ouais c'est fou ça cyril sa
cellule à ce soir c'était l'odeur mais
en fait c'était moi qui avait fabriqué
l'odeur humaine mais dit qu'est ce que
tu n'aimes pas j'avais midi la piste
dacourt de fromage votre avec soyaux et
vous qui nous avez vous jamais non mais
je vois je vois les ravages geste atroce
ils seront très bien après demain quand
on va leur montrer tout 16e cesser
demain dira même terrible ces deux
masses africaines quand on va leur
montrer tout ça ça va être parce qu'il
m'a quand même dit bertrand il est venu
vers moi quand il y avait rihanna mais
je peux pas lui rien de tel quand même
parce que parce que et noura hamdi tu
lui as fait tu fais la bise et jb oui je
vais pas lui voler une pelle vous avez
vous êtes vous être militant va
maintenant je vous ai vu que c'était ce
n'est pas d'être tout nu ou banon mais
enfin j'ai l'impression d'être le seul
et ça choque mais nous aimons aller on
avait tout donné on est tous du tissu on
va tous duty voilà ça vaut bertrand
allez bon ça va mieux c'est chelou quand
même